*upbeat light accordion and guitar music*
Hello! *woman gasps*
Weeeeee
People love it!
I got one!
*rhythmically intense electronic music*
*upbeat light accordion and guitar music*
*house electronic music*
*cash register ding*
I wish these salads could be tastier.
*chimes* Women: charlie?  Fish: ad stock is for your kinda flavor.
What's that?
It's Kool-Aid liquid.
But you are Kool-Aid.
Well people get freaked out when you drink from you own head.
What you got there duke?
Jay and Duke talking action figures. My idea.
Love it!
It takes place in ancient Cleveland.
*laughing* Cleveland, I love it babe.
I'm not your babe.
You weren't saying that this morning when you were like hmmmm.
Silk Vanilla tastes better than milk on cereal. It has 50% more calcium.
Really?
Leslie guess what today is.
It's hump day.
What what! wooo!
*screaming*
Rest is here on the wings of Lunesta, and stay asleep so you can wake up feeling rested.
*magical chimes*
*pleasant sigh*
*sniffing*
Hey buddy let's take a little walk.
You're gonna wanna palm tree up the fish. Keep unicorning until the smiley face of the soccer shoe, until the second sea horse on your teapot, and then you should be lightbulbs.
Did you get all that rubber ducky?